so you live in you're in california
yeah i'm in uh i live actually i live
officially i live in alameda
but it's basically a bay area it's just
like
oakland like a little like it's a little
island
right off of oakland basically like an
old port town or something like that
nice yeah it's really nice in fact i
i'm um i'm appreciating
because i have a suit i am super early
i'm super sensitive to kind of the
i don't know the lack of this like lack
of soul like like track houses
and shopping malls and all that
kind of stuff man it just i it just all
that stuff just
makes me sick and nauseous like
physically
so i we found a place that's like right
in a really old neighborhood
like historical houses and you know they
have laws
because they're houses that you know i
think
most new housing developments are
so strange it's like they build the
houses to look like look like houses
yeah that's such a good way to say it
look like they're like simulations house
simulation simulacra
yeah totally totally so well welcome
yeah
i'm glad you could come on it's been
looking good yeah sorry it took so long
to
to get it all together you know i i've
been
i've had some my life has been crazy for
the past year and a half and so
it's only just in the past few months
that i feel like i
said okay i know that there's a bunch of
people that said they wanted to talk to
me i needed to kind of get back to them
and so
so i just remembered i said i remember a
guy saying stock had written a few
messages that kind of
flew by i flew over my head so so yeah
i'm happy it worked out
yeah me too me too the uh yeah i've been
noticing you've been having more
conversations lately with people
i i think that did that intentional or
it is intentional it's hard to totally
understand
why i it's kind of an intuitive thing
that i'm doing i don't
completely understand it i think it has
something to do with jordan peterson
kind of reappearing
in on the horizon but at the same time
not appearing on the horizon kind of
being there but not being there
um and i don't know if that's it seems
like that may be that's maybe what's
motivating
this in my but i'm not i don't know why
it's hard to explain it it's
just this intuitive thing that i all of
a sudden had a sense that okay i need to
also i think i think i think what it is
is that i think that in the past maybe
year and a half i've been consolidating
the people that have been following what
i'm doing trying to
be more in contact with the people that
understand that are wanting to develop
it
and uh not not trying to reach out and
have communications that'll challenge me
and so i think that that's it i think
that seeing jordan kind of reappear
in the on the horizon has made me think
okay i need to not just focus on my
thing i need to really
uh push myself so that i don't stagnate
in this space so
who's the person the hardest person that
i could that i could talk to
like the person that would be the most
challenging and so i found these kind of
more hard-line atheists to talk to just
because i feel like it's it's the it's
the most challenging thing so
i totally got i really appreciate that
sense
like i there's something about that that
i really relate to and
it actually brings to something i wanted
to ask you about which is like your role
right in all of this and i because for
me
this has been i totally relate to what
you're saying you basically said i'm
like oh you've been talking to more
people is that intentionally you're like
yes but it's hard to say why
[Laughter]
yeah well we work with we work so much
with intuition
so much of what we do is intuitive and
so i try
i try not to to stop the intuition too
much when it's happening you know
yeah well specifically what's so
interesting about this
because it's so conversational obviously
and
is and i think this has been the case
for me
i mean anything that's been good in my
life has been some sense in which i've
been intuitively responding to something
something speaks to me right and so i
just kind of find myself
following it um because i'm really bad
personally i'm really bad at paying
attention to anything that's not
interesting to me
like i just oh man
i'm so much the same right you know i oh
yeah i've been
i've been you know i luckily i'm married
to a woman
like a wonderful woman in that case but
i i've always
like i've never done anything which was
going to make myself me see a cure in
the world i've always
both of us we've always just done what
we knew what the right thing was or the
the thing that really was was telling it
was kind of
shining in front of us that we had to we
take a grasp of
uh no matter where it led us and so so
you know yeah
it's a great it's better to live that
way it's it's riskier but it's it's uh
it's more fulfilling oh totally well and
then and then
and then as you follow it then the thing
that you've been interested in
kind of comes out and it be then i mean
that's what circle it was for me and
circling was the same thing
i'm just like whoa the moment like me
and my friend noticed it and we're like
what is that and then
ten years later there's a movement in a
language trail and a methodology and
and people it's funny because people
kind of ask me questions about it like
and i guess i can talk about it as if in
retrospect as if i knew what i was
looking at but actually i didn't know
what i was looking at
but but it didn't surprise me as it as
it started to come
into into flourishing it's like there
was but
so there's a connection between guy you
know that moment of
where something like shined out to me
and then the response to it
and then as it's in retrospect i can pin
it all together on some level
but the connection between the guy
that's after it's revealed
and the guy before it's revealed like
how the hell does it know like what are
we actually responding to
that's always been the mystery to me
yeah of how do we know i think you're i
think you're right i
i agree yeah i think that that's the one
thing
you know four years ago when i just
started making these youtube videos
it was the same you know all of a sudden
i was kind of put into a situation and
kind of thrust into a space that i had
not planned for that i had not thought
that i would ever be in
and uh but it was that was it like that
was the path in front of me and i
thought okay let's do this you know and
uh
not knowing exactly what the plan was
but then
as you said as you start to move then
things start to clarify
and then you you can start to understand
okay so this is where i'm going this is
what i'm doing and then you can
fine-tune you know what you're what
you're doing but i feel like now is a
moment
again where i i feel like there's
there has now there's something else
like there's something else kind of
kind of calling and so we'll see i don't
know i don't know where it's going to
leave me but
it's okay you know it's all good
i just love the way i just love the way
the matter of fact
the thing that you said like the way
that you said that i'm like
have you been doing it intentionally
yeah i don't know
exactly why
but it's hard to explain this to people
like people who don't live
that way because i for example like i
started icon carving i
could have thought you could be a
professional icon carver because that
doesn't exist like it's a job that
doesn't exist no one does it
and so i and then i started doing it
professionally and i remember someone
asked me
about uh what i was doing and uh
and said i can't wait to see your work
in five years and i looked at him and i
said five years like
i'm not sure i'll still be doing this in
five years and they didn't understand
how i could think that way but
it's like i don't know what i'll be
doing in five years and and uh it's
totally fine with me yeah i don't i
don't have uh
i have no problem in imagining that i'll
become somewhere completely
somewhere else if i'm in the same place
and it's still
kind of it's bringing life to the around
me and it's bringing life in
in my own experience then then i'll stay
here that's fine
right right you know there was a
guy that you interviewed that wrote a
book called is it
is it redemption guy he's a historian
what's that a dominion from holland
yeah i went i i watched the interview
which i really liked and i got the book
and i've been
i've been listening to the book actually
which is really good
but he's a great writer he's such a
reality yes man
i i i always kind of i've been getting
to know to what degree
how we i've always got i've always had a
sense that
that you know we're so deeply christian
right in ways that
whether or not we go to church or even
believe in god or anything you almost
can't be western without
being christian right at such a deep
level but he exemplifies it really
clearly in a way that i can like whoa
it's like it's so deep in in the
difference
and i and it's interesting because i've
actually been thinking about
what it must have been like to be christ
right where like that
like what's so what's take it for
granted at this point
right of all of our conscience the way
our conscience speaks to us the fact
that like i feel bad if i treat somebody
like on a lo and lower status meaningly
or i see somebody else do it and like
it's just obvious that we shouldn't do
that
and like we feel bad about like all the
different pre-reflective responses to
the world that seemed so
self-evident or something that
that a lot of that stuff was not there
and so i'm just imagining
like what the hell was it like to be
christ to hear yourself
saying these things where there was no
basis upon which for it to be even
remotely intelligible
like imagine yourself like saying
yeah like what if they hit you turn the
other cheek
like how the hell is he even supposed to
know what that means right
yeah i think i think i see it the way
that i would phrase it is more
like to meet him like i i struggle to
him i think that
it it when you read the scripture you
get a sense that he
that christ knew exactly what he was
doing compared to most people
but i think that i the way that i would
experience your the dilemma is more to
say like if i had met christ
you know 2 000 years ago i don't think i
think most of us would not have
recognized
what was happening i think we would have
been as dumbfounded as most people
around
and yeah i mean we might have been some
of the people that thought that he
should die because
what he was doing was just like you know
what what is going on you know what is
happening
it looks like you're gonna take over
like you're gonna take over politically
but then you
keep talking about you know you know
loving your
enemy and all these weird things that
it's just very odd
and so i i really do think i have it's
weird because i have sympathy like i
have a lot of sympathy
for the pharisees when i read scripture
because everybody thinks they would have
been one of the
the disciples that say and and they
wouldn't have been like the pharisees
but
statistically you wouldn't have been oh
man you probably
definitely would have been like the
pharisee not only that but even the
disciples sometimes didn't know what
christ was doing they're kind of like
okay so he said that now like what
what what is that i thought he said this
before so what's going on
and they look they look confused all
through christ's life until
until the until pentecost and then at
pentecost it seems like everything kind
of
like they're they see they finally see
okay we've been doing this kind of we've
been doing this thing for several years
and now
okay this is what it's about like this
is what it's supposed to be and then
there's and then there's this scene
where peter
stands up finally and like speaks to the
thousands of people
and has this like you know this
convincing and it's because he finally
got it after
you know more than three years like what
exactly was going on
that's pretty crazy to think about
totally like so just to put yourself
in christ's position where like
i'm because i'm wondering if it's
something similar that what we're
talking about it's like well
like what are you doing are you saying
that intentionally are you doing these
interviews intentionally like
well yeah like it is intentional like
i'm not sure why
right this kind of whatever that
position is it's something similar where
it's like
it's not predicated on something that's
completely revealed and
clear in some mental way
but there's an intuitive sense and a
response to something
that's very very deep that you trust and
i'm i'm wondering if that's a little bit
i don't know just putting my in the
story as i've been thinking about this i
don't really know that much about
christ's life
um but like well the thing about christ
is that
especially the way christians understand
it is that he did have
that knowledge he wasn't like us kind of
fumbling around because
you can see that he there are certain
scenes in scripture that are there to
show you that
he knew exactly what he was doing like
he would take he would he would quote
certain verses from scripture like he
would open up the torah and then he
would read certain verses
to help people understand what was going
on and he was trying to
and then when others didn't understand
he would tell them it's like like you
fools like you don't know you don't even
see what's happening like you have it in
front of you and you don't see it and so
sometimes christ is actually pretty
harsh on the disciples because
they're more like us they're more like
fumbling along trying to kind of
get a sense whereas he he seemed to have
had a kind of clarity that is difficult
to um
right that's difficult to to frame let's
say
does did he have a basis did he ever
reference
or give any sense of the basis upon
which he was
his clarity was about yeah well well
that he was god you mean besides
that yeah he decided he was he was
that he was the son of man that he was
all these images of
the manifestation of god in the world
like you know
that's probably the the best places
where he kind of shows
the clarity but yeah okay the fact that
he
he encompasses like for example like
there's one there's one place
where people ask him like what you know
what's the law like what's the
and he says love love god and love
uh your your neighbor as yourself and i
mean that's to show you what
how much he understood because there's
three there's hundreds of laws in
scripture
and that law is not even in the like ten
commandments
but he says he takes this little law in
in the i don't know if it's in leviticus
or
takes this little law he says this is
the fullness of the law
and so you can see that he's actually
changing he's taking all the
prescriptions and transforming them into
modes of being
into the highest mode of being yeah and
so it's like i mean he knew exactly what
he was doing like he knew exactly what
he was saying
i'm just trying to transfer himself in
that position imagining like
so at at what point
did he start to unless it was instant
unless he knew it like
in the womb like when did he know
that he was who he was do you know does
he
it doesn't it doesn't say in scripture
but there are many
stories um like legends of christ that
he
uh you know the idea that he was
performing miracles even as a child
um there there's a there's the verse
there's the the place in scripture where
he's in the temple at 12 years old and
he's teaching
all the elders and so
the mary forgets christ in the temple
they they go
to visit the temple and then they think
that he's with another family so they
leave and then they just leave jesus
there for like a whole day until the
next day
and then when they come back they find
they find jesus
sitting there in the temple and teaching
all the elders of
israel and and and uh
and then she says what do you like i
can't believe it we forgot you why where
why didn't you come with us you know and
she's a little bit annoyed with him
and he answers he says no i'm doing the
work of my father.
and so that i think that that's that
text is there to show us that even
at a very young age he knew what he was
and he knew
like what his role was yeah but there
are stories in all kinds of
just a knowingness
hearing that what do you mean i wouldn't
say that i'd be like oh yeah it's
from your father right it sounds like
there's just a deep knowingness
yeah but there it's there's a lot of
there's our there are a lot of stories
like that in other cultures as well
stories of you know the child that
speaks when they're born
um you know the the child that's born
full grown
you get that in the in the dao for
example the idea that lao tzu was born
full grown and you get it there's a lot
of there's a lot of different traditions
about children that are born full grown
and i think that all those traditions
are there to talk about the
the capacity that there are beings that
that are
manifesting something so fully that they
they they
they do it from the from birth you know
and i think that that's
for sure that's how christians
understand christ as being
you know the the full incarnation of of
the father and and that this was not
something that developed in him
but was really you know was there at the
outset
right i just it just i don't know if
i've ever quite
thought about it i mean i was i have
been thinking about this but like
now in this conversation i find myself
putting myself
imagining from within christ
at some point starting to know
or maybe just the moment i'm aware is
the moment i'm
how would i what how would i know that
and what would it be like to know that
like god that just sounds so intense
just imagine that you're like going
along and then you just find yourself
knowing
that you're god
i think i think i think that i try not
to think of that that way because
the thing about the thing about knowing
is that you when
the things you know you know it's not
it's not like you find yourself knowing
in the sense that it's not an accidental
thing you know
um once you know something it's like
it's a form of clarity it's not it's not
a
once it happens to you let's say you so
you you could take
you could take the moments you take the
moments that
you've had moments of clarity let's say
where all of a sudden everything kind of
lines up into place
and all of a sudden you know exactly
like
you know exactly it's as if you're kind
of one with your out with your outside
and one with your inside and you know
exactly what you're doing
you know exactly why you're doing it's
like everything's lined up and
we i think most people have these little
moments like that like
say these little moments and i think
that if you want to imagine
christ it's to imagine that that's all
he is
yeah that his whole existence is that
clarity which it can't really imagine it
but you can expand it out of your
you can expand it out of your little
moments of clarity let's say
right i know that for me in those
moments of like in that
clarity it's usually
yeah it's i usually don't represent
those moments until someone kind of asks
me about it
right and then when i go to try to
describe
what i may be clear about i'll have this
experience of like
having a difficult time putting into
words but you're right there's something
that i
i know that i can't account for
so i would imagine it's like but then
imagining living your whole life
from that place that's amazing
yeah and it it seems like if you read
the
if you follow the the tradition it seems
like it's possible like if
you look at uh saints who live their
whole life
in prayer and you know live an aesthetic
take up an aesthetic life and really
kind of sacrifice everything to
to live in that clarity and that prayer
in that
self self denial of the passions and
and also embrace of love towards their
neighbor then you meet
characters in the tradition that have
that like there are these images
these stories of saint seraphim of sarov
who's a recent saint
who's a modern saint and uh you know he
lived in the forest with a bear and you
know like he
just all of it was just this almost
mythological figure
but one one day one of his disciples was
talking to him like someone who was
trying to get some teaching from him
um and he kind of asked i forget what he
asked me that's not something like
i'd like to have a glimpse of what it
can be like what life can
be you know what we can reach and then
saint seraphim
looked at him and then in before his
very eyes san serif became like a flame
like a living flame and uh and and he
saw
like who said therefore really was he
saw this this
this being that was completely burning
you know
in god and and then it was just for a
split second and then it was gone like
it was just like i saw
through the veil let's say for a moment
and so it seems like those characters
exist even today like on mount athos
there are all these
stories of contemporary elders who who
you know who do things that we can't
that that people don't believe are
possible like you know they they they
have all these
powers or whatever and they they they
commune
in spirit together so these monks who
lives in caves who don't who don't
talk to each other will nonetheless
speak to each other in spirit and
you know they can tell someone oh you
know uh remind
so and so about about this thing that he
told me yesterday
and they're like wait you didn't see him
yesterday but he did in this kind of
yeah this this higher sphere let's say
it's funny i never talk about this kind
of stuff you've got me on a weird
space
[Laughter]
is this the kind of stuff you talk about
with your brother i mean
it's the kind of no it's the kind of
stuff that i don't talk about especially
that what i just said now because
it's the kind of thing which i think is
secondary to what
yeah what is most important but it
because it's it
looks kind of magical that it attracts
attention and so it can
it can i think it can sometimes take
people astray because they like the idea
of
people having powers and people having
more and so they it's almost like a
science fiction version so and i think
it's totally possible
i don't deny these things but i i don't
think that they're that important
yeah totally well they're kind of neat
well i think what i'm getting from this
conversation is like as you're talking
about it
i mean there's just these it's it's
neato to get inside of it a bit
right and like get the mystery of it
like
of of of just the sense that that
on some level i'm sure christ had a
subjectivity
right he had an experience he was having
right but he had a knowing in which
what's really interesting to think about
is how does he even represent that to
himself when he pictures what he is
if it's if i'm god when he thinks of
himself
as god i mean by definition he probably
doesn't have a picture
right in his mind right like these are
like these are ways of kind of maybe
getting at the
mystery of it right we're getting close
to it i that that's what i'm
experiencing as we're talking
yeah i mean i don't know i i think that
those
those are usually not that the avenues
that i go on in terms of trying to
understand this stuff just because
the the best it because it's
you can't it's hard to imagine what
a higher form of consciousness is you
know unless you experience it and so
it it can become a bit arbitrary to cry
to try to
and so the only way for me to try to
understand it is to
compare let's say the moments of
of focus and of clarity and of love that
i have in my life
compared to the moments where i'm just a
zombie
sleepy sleep walking through my
existence and so it's like
when i if i can compare those two types
of modes of experience
then then that's when i can say oh okay
so
maybe there's something like that but
higher up like there's even more
and and i can i can that's the only way
that i can kind of imagine
uh the moreness of it but i i don't
but i but yeah but i don't i don't see
it as a
yeah yeah yeah i think that's the only
way that i can really kind of
peek into that mystery well you you know
you mentioned something i usually don't
like to come at it like this
or it's rare because it has a tendency
to have people think
some you know like something fantastical
like and that's not
the best way of going going about it
which is an awareness of
that there is a listening i would
imagine that seems to presuppose a
listening
that you're s that you speak into or an
awareness of people
which i think starts to get into some of
just the questions i had about your
you know your role so far in terms of
you know being on youtube and talking
about symbolism
like i'm just curious about what what is
your like what what is this
you have right like who are you talking
to like what
what have you found out so far yeah well
look
i think um
i think that if i have a role i think
that i kind of fell into it and that
which is fine which is totally fine
i think that i couldn't have planned for
it but it seems like what i'm doing
is i'm offering uh a
ladder to people who who have been
living in a kind of materialist
reductionist world and need the few
lower steps to to reach up and then
you know kind of have a fuller more
let's say enchanted vision of reality
and so it's all i it seems like that's
what i've been doing and i have
i i have ways of talking to people
that will awaken that intuition yeah and
so
i try to constantly look for so if i
have a like i said my main
strategy which is it is a strategy is i
always try to surprise
people with meaning and so which is why
i'll when i talk about a subject i'll
i'll try to find
a an extremely high subject which is
let's say like some bible story or
some you know medieval architecture or
something that is very high
and then i'll find an example which is
as low as possible
like how you experience your coffee cup
or how you you know or some
marvel movie or some some kind of low
thing in order to
to jolt people's under to jolt people
into an experience you know
it's like a mini i always say i try to
create mini zen cohens like little mini
ones
where people go oh okay wait a minute i
i hadn't thought about that and then all
of a sudden it connects two wires in
their experience and
then they have a little spark i would
say like if if i do that
then i'm happy like that's pretty much
what i what i would like to be doing
right so to have people
take those couple of steps where they
can get an intuitive glimpse
of another world that their current the
current step that they're on
like won't allow them to see right
exactly
right yeah that's a good way to
understand it yeah that's a good way to
understand it so
so i think that that's been that's
really been if i can kind of reduce
what i'm doing to one thing i would say
that that's it and i also i
also i think one of the other things i'm
i i'm trying to do
is to reinvigorate uh
christians who are blase
who are or think that this is just wrote
like they they don't see
how much power is in the the story how
much power is in the ritual how much
power
is in and so to kind of get people
excited a little bit
again about you know about the story of
christ about
the stories of scripture um and so i
would say to me that's the second thing
i'm trying to do
yeah okay so the other the other thing
is is that there's a whole world of
people
who go to church but there's a little
bit of that that they're not awake
necessarily to the living-ness of the
story
and you want to like in some sense do
something similar with them or they can
they can become awake to the tradition
that they're actually inside of
yeah and it seems it also seems to be
the most of the people watching my
videos seem to be young
people uh you know like late 20s
some people that are like either mid-20s
to
early 30s people who are either in
college or just finished college and
have had to kind of deal with all that
intellectual pressure that you go
through when you go to university you
know especially if you go in a liberal
arts
world um and it's like they
they they're looking also for
ways to explain or to give
strength to something that they might
feel intuitively
and so they have an intuition about
something but then they don't
necessarily have the tools to
to fully expound it and so and so i
think people are grateful
to have those tools i think that's one
of the things that jordan peterson did
too
is that he was giving ways of and john
viveki man john vicki has been amazing
for that where
he gives you words and tools that you
can say you can talk about
combinatorial explosion because all of a
sudden you have a term
and then you can explain the term but
once you've explained it to someone they
understand what it is
and so then you can kind of move on and
then you can talk about
relevance realization it's like that's
an awesome term to help people
kind of step into something that they
maybe they don't have access to little i
think i'm doing something similar but
with
images and yeah analogies helping people
see the patterns that they haven't seen
yet totally well you know i think i had
i had an experience
um
i'm not sure if i got your role i i
thought i said to my wife in this moment
right that i was like i think i'm really
getting jonathan's role here
um but i think i think it is gotten
symbolism too
i'm not sure but like maybe both are the
same that's kind of a cool
position to be and right where they get
symbolism is getting your role
that's kind of a cool place i would
imagine being here um
but it was a there was a moment actually
where uh
you know a lot of the a lot of the
apocalypse started happening and
but i wasn't quite i wasn't quite
getting it totally it all just started
it still looked like the same thing to
me and then i was watching one night
i i think it may have been
a day or i was just finding out about
the the whole
the whole the guy that the cop that
killed the person
on tv right yeah and somewhere around
there and then there are three
hurricanes and then
like 20 riots or something like that and
and the plague right all
happening at once i was watching the
news and something about
for some reason if the news just reached
out and it went
it hit it hit me i was like well wait a
minute no we're
actually this is a different it felt
like time itself had changed
right like this is different we're in a
different temporality
like that's how i would i would put it
but i didn't i wasn't
left the inside didn't leave me with any
sense of orientation
right i was like everything that i could
grab
onto to try to understand it didn't
quite hold
and then a few days later i was
listening i was watching your videos and
i think it was the first
video or two after that
where you actually came out and talked
about the actual event you talked about
that you took your time with it right
because it took something to really
understand it
but when you when you explained when you
especially when you explained
the phenomena of all of us watching
right this man get killed right and the
and
and that you explained the phenomena of
how we were identified with the cop
we were identified with the person being
killed and the converses
and all the symbolism that you put
around it and you explicitly said like
hey sorry guys
and this is you also and you also talked
about
the fall of the west in the burning of
the statues and you
gave that great explanation i love this
explanation like
you move into a house and there's still
the past family still has their pictures
up you're like
you're going to want to take them down
it was like
just that's like that's so
that's so true um and it
and you said hey guys listen i'm sorry i
don't have any i don't have any
solutions all i can do is kind of
articulate what i think is maybe
happening
but there was this way where that
i i felt like after that i found myself
in a place inside of it
and i was like i felt myself being able
to grip onto something
um that was a bit ecstatic and very very
orienting and i remember i was like
oh [ __ ] like this is i look to my my
wife brianna's like i think this is this
is his role
whatever it is he's doing i think he
just did it
oh well good thank you well i'm happy
that i that i kind of helped you
get some clarity in that in the strange
moment it's got it's it's been
this year the thing about what's
happening is that
time is really accelerating and so the
shifts
in let's say the shifts that you felt
this kind of
temporal shift for this shift of worlds
like as if the ground is moving
underneath you
yeah it's usually something that would
happen like every
few hundred years but now it's happening
every few years
right and so you know i felt it happened
at the last
in 2016 i felt it happen and now and now
i'm feeling it happen
and so it's like four years is a short
time for the world to change
so much in terms of the whole ground
kind of shifting underneath you
for people who are intuitive it's very
very
existentially difficult because you feel
it like you
really it's like it stops you from
sleeping and you feel it
that you feel like the world is changing
and it's almost like it's a
you know you're like you're tied to a
giant gear and it's like stretching you
you know
um and so so i i understand what you're
saying and so i feel it
very much so yeah and uh and so i i also
try to
so hopefully if we can at least help
people feel that
the despair which goes with that or you
know at least if people understand
what's going on then
even though you can't stop it you don't
feel just
falling like you don't feel like you're
just falling like at least there seems
to be
yeah some frame around what's happening
for you to understand
yeah absolutely yeah there's a cert
there's so
that's an also very interesting thing in
itself of like
like if i don't have a frame around
what's happening if there's no if
there's no place for me to kind of get a
handle on something like what i get a
handle on may just
actually what i got to handle on is if
there is no handle right maybe that's
the thing that i got my handle on but
there is this element of
and i don't know where i stand in a lot
in in in this whole issue because i see
because i really feel the same thing
that you're talking about of where
i'm like whoa like there's weird there's
like existential
changes that are happening at such a
level right
that used to take thousands of years to
happen and they're just boom
boom boom happening closer or closer
like
and i for me there's really this element
of like well i'm on a ride here
i don't know exactly what i'm writing
right
but like i'm on a ride and and when i
hear people
respond like right what like
what did you just yeah oh man
it i i know but i i the thing is the
thing is that this ride has been going
for a while
like the ride has been lasting a few
centuries now
the thing we don't realize is that the
rides slowed down
after you know the tens and tens and
tens of millions of people that were
slaughtered in world war
ii so because world war ii uh
ended in um such a mass carnage
and and two nuclear explosions then
it's as if the rides slowed down
for one two generations but that's it
it's get it's starting up again it's the
same ride that brought
the world into the revolutions uh after
the enlightenment and so
and so it's it's only we just had we
just were fortunate to be in a pause
you know after mass slaughter but so
it's not pretty what's happened
on the horizon is not uh i'm smiling as
i say it i always laugh in the worst
moments
but it's not it's not pretty we it's
it's the
yeah well i think well the laughter
actually is i mean there's there's
something into
in the laughter that i think is
revealing
about what we're facing i'm not exactly
sure why this is what i was just kind of
trying to get
i haven't been able to quite put my
finger on it
because when i see people talk about the
world and the time
in a way that's like has a sense of
urgency
and it's good nature of trying to it's
like almost like trying to take
existence and turn it into a problem to
solve
right there's a i mean i appreciate the
impulse but i just get this sense i'm
like
i'm like this is no we're inside of
something like
it seems like that category mistake you
know what i'm saying
like this exactly that's such a great
way to put it
it seems like there's the category area
going on here pretty big one like
you think you're gonna sell existence
okay that's a that's a little bit of a
problem
no i totally i totally agree with you
and and you can see
the arrogance of the like you can see
the errants
arrogance of the systems of of of mass
control and of mass information like
there's they really do believe that
they're gonna get there like they're
gonna
they believe that they're moving in that
direction and so it's a tower valuable
moment
it really is uh and that story also
doesn't doesn't end well
you know right and there's something for
me
about
those handles that like well i think i
would put it like this i think it's
maybe maybe i mean we could use
heidegger's help here because it's it's
there's the
there's the quality of truth there's a
truthness of like that sense where he
talks about it's not correct
right it's well it's not
not correct it's also correct but
there's a there's an element of that
um that which was concealed is revealed
right there's the truthness or the
happening-ness of truth
which has a kind of transcendence to it
like even if you
even if what gets revealed is that
you're in hell and you're going to be in
hell for the next 20
you know whatever right there is
something that laughs
and there's a basis there which i think
has to do with
i don't know is it have to do with just
having a semblance of of of being in
truth
yeah well and there's a list there is
like there is this there like i think
you're you're right in the sense that
the disclosure itself like this
this this capacity to
to kind of get a sense to see the
pattern to get a sense of what's
happening even if
what it's what is happening is is
horrible
uh it it does offer you a kind of ex
a small little ecstasy or a small little
mystical
mystical experience and uh and a sense
of freedom
within it too you know it's because you
you all of a sudden you pull back and
you see it come together right you have
this
this this revelation and you know christ
talks about
how he talks about how all
all must be revealed and he it seems
like christ inaugurated
this process where things would just be
revealed one after the other
and the revelation is not positive i
think that
i think that it's always like a mix of
both so there's
there are aspects of the this this
disclosure of the world which
is positive and there's disclosure an
aspect of it which is a scandal
and so as as let's say christianity
revealed the highest mystery of theosis
of the the purpose of creation of as
being
becoming one with god it's like also
what is going to be revealed is all
our perversity all our are
all our passions in their you know in
their worst forms of desire to control
of a desire to
to to live only for pleasure all of this
stuff that is now rampant in our society
it's kind of like those two had to
happen it's like it had to happen it has
to it has to show itself
um yeah yeah yeah
it's it's a showing right well
it's those little ecstasies they kind of
give a sense of freedom
i think also when i got i think this
starts to get in some of my questions
about
symbolism right so when i first started
watching
watching you i was there was there was a
sense in which i was i was
i was familiar with the with the
language that you spoke i was familiar
with what you were talking about because
i
i had obsessively read young when i was
in high school
um and so i was very familiar with the
way he talked about
like symbolism right in the in in the
jungian way that he did
but what i think when i really but there
was something different about the way
you were talking about it right
than than he was yeah because i don't i
don't i i
on the other hand don't read you yeah
people just don't seem to
believe me but it's just true i don't
know i don't think he'd like him no
like i don't really know i think he'd
find it really i think you would if you
read jung i'm imagining
like if you read jung it's like it'd be
interesting but i don't think he would
really be compelling
um because he'd be he has some implicit
horizons that i think are well
it's what makes your work your work to
me and not jung's
is actually when it came to this and i
think this starts to speak to the
also these moments of ecstasy these
moments of release
right and i want to talk about what's
good about that right
um when you said
no it's like i think it's when you
talked about you know the symbol
you know i think you were looking it was
it's some video where you were talking
about
the symbol of something and he said look
the symbol
is actually um the symbol
is is one of the ways or the that
picture is one of the ways that the
pattern substantiates itself
right the the picture isn't the symbol
right the the picture it just happened i
got the sense so you didn't say this but
i got the sense it's like it's a
condensed
it it brought all the pieces enough in a
like a small enough space-time right
picture such that you could see the
whole pattern in front of you but it
itself is just an obstacion in the
pattern
that happens in reality in over longer
time
frames that if you could understand it
you could see those patterns
yeah that's a good way to understand it
that is that
the the symbols that appear to us more
most clearly are those that are the most
condensed you could say like you said
that they that they the word symbol
actually means
means two things that are thrown
together and so there's this idea that
symbolism itself
is bringing together of elements and so
that you see them as one you see the
pattern or the ordering of it
um and so and so the symbols the more
proper symbols
you know let's say like an icon or you
know a church building or something
which is
which we tend to think as symbolic
rather than you know your
everyday life which is also symbolic but
let's say the liturgical space or the
sacred spaces
they condense it in in a manner which is
more
accessible or makes it accessible to us
so so we
we can kind of get it once you see the
pattern then it
it actually then if you're sensitive
then it'll start to
to uh let's say bleed out into other
aspects of your reality and
then you realize that hey you know my
body is also made that way and
a relationship with others also has that
has similar patterns and you know our
societies and our stories all of it
is actually manifesting these these
sacred patterns to a certain extent
yeah and so the symbol is a is a
is one instant of the pattern
right like a little incarnation of a of
a of a pr
of an essence or a
and so then that's what i think that's
when i really got it's like oh you're
talking about you're
actually talking about reality oh yeah
that might be the difference between you
yeah it's not
just psychological yeah and so it really
is the psychological is part of it for
sure your psyche also has that
shape and it's really important because
because we are
human beings are logos let's say are
we we have reason and we we have
consciousness
therefore we are kind of we are the
place where symbolism actually kind of
happens but it's nonetheless is
also happening in the world because we
are the
we're like the funnel through which the
world you know has meaning uh
and this is something which i'm not
making up like this is something that i
take from the church fathers especially
saint maximus the confessor this idea
that the man is the might
is the ultimate microcosm and that the
entire cosmos
you know condenses into into the human
person
um and it's we can understand it in a in
a you can use
cog site and now to understand it or you
can use theory the meaning and
and the problem of of of of emanation
and complexity to now see that yes
conscious beings are like the funnel
through which
this potentiality that's out there this
kind of indefinite potentiality
comes in and then you know becomes
uh becomes meaning becomes
becomes a world right okay so
so i want to slow down there a little
bit so that the
the you just said a bunch right there so
the the yeah
sorry the the the infinite potential of
the endless
potential comes in and what you're
saying is that the
psyche you could say is the place
that it that the psyche
is the place where that potential
gathers into a world
i mean it's not just the psyche it's the
person
it's more embodied than just the psyche
it's but but it is the person like the
human person
both in terms of mind but also in terms
of acting out in the world that's why
it's
uh it's pes it's it's a perspective you
know
you know and jordan talks about this all
the time where the categories of being
are actually categories of action
they're not
static categories the way even the way
that plato tended to tend
to think of uh of forms there's
something off about that
you know say maximus the confessor talks
about how the the idea of things or the
form and you know this
the essence the way that the platon is
talked about are actually
also the end of things
those two things together so he kind of
takes he takes a lot of aristotelian
categories and platonic
jams them into this thing which is logos
which is it's also the reason the
purpose
and that makes it that brings it into
the the human
back into the human person because those
purposes come into
come out come out of us or join in us
you know and so the reason why we have a
category called rock is a human reason
but it's also totally objective it's not
a
subjective reason it's objective but
it's a human reason
right it joins into us i don't that
makes sense that makes sense it makes a
lot of sense like it makes a whole lot
of sense to me
it's a it's really cool it's it's just
really it's it's
it's it's it's it almost it's so cool
it's so so
it's so yeah it's so there's something
about it so constituting like i get this
sense of as we're talking about it like
the sense of it is
it's like oh it's like we're talking
about what constitutes
and everything's constituted in some
level right the context
constituents of something that is
feels like and this is one of the things
i've always really
i mean this is what philosophy is really
you know i think that
specifically like heidegger and yeah
we're still ponte and you know i didn't
quite
exactly understand why the hell i
started reading those guys
right that like you know during my early
20s um
because i didn't understand anything
that i was reading like but there was
something that that was being shown
especially heidegger there are some
passages in heidegger which i'm sure he
doesn't even understand like i'm pretty
sure
yeah but there are some passages in
heidegger that are pure gold like
they he definitely had an intuition
about
right about this the way the world shows
itself to us and
uh and i think that he opens a door
towards even though in a way he was not
a he was he was almost like
he was very much a modernist and he was
very much trying to
deal with some of the problems of
materialism and all of this but i think
that he opens a door
which can then bring us take us out of
it and so i i really
that's why i use heidegger i use them
implicitly i don't
i do quote him sometimes explicitly but
i there is a
heidegger pro program running in my mind
as well
i have a few programs running and that's
one of them for sure is heidegger
yeah totally well it's like it's a and
this is a very set like what do you talk
about symbolism right in the patterns
the way it
lays itself out right in the logos right
the gathering
laying right the thing that kind of this
sense of the
i mean that's really that's one thing
for me too is just kind of really
getting that no it's like anything
one any any perception that you have is
a perception to the degree that's
intelligible to you
right into the degree it's intelligent
it means that it's gathered
in its intelligibility and what you
experience actually is its
its intelligibility and its being or the
same
the same thing right that's right
and that's that's really the key and the
fact that you get that
is is so important so few people
get there and and you know i was talking
to some atheists recently and you know
uh like they mentioned don hoffman for
example and
and you can see it's everybody has that
problem which is
that even though they start to perceive
the necessity of
something like consciousness for the
necessity of is
they always still want to posit like
some
world out there that another world like
some other world that's out there
that's not the one that we're that we're
having
the experience of and it's like how do
you how can you posit that and
like because you're still there like
you're you're still it's like a weird
thing where you you have to self-deny
and so it's almost like there's there's
a falseness to that
uh and so i think it's much better i
think that
the phenomenological perspective is much
better because it it says this is it
like this is the
there is no other world besides the
world that we
encounter and we can we can make
abstractions and we can create
abstract constructions out of it things
like things like science things like
you know the solar system or atoms and
all of this stuff but it
still happens within the frame of our
immediate
of this this design right of this this
care
that you that you perceive that you that
you
things lay themselves out and manifest
appear to you
because you care about them and you
can't avoid it and it is relevance
realization it's like
you can't avoid that yeah yeah
and that's the thing but it is really
all the way down i i like how
kind of pedigree like gets at that like
being in the world is
is you're not a being that then cares
like you're the fact that you're a being
is already a
you are a carefulness right you that's
how the
it's that care that gathers the facts to
show up in the particular
as you do science and all that kind of
stuff is all
downstream from right this primordial
kind of sense of care yeah yeah
that thing that kind of that that sense
of really getting symbolism
when did that happen for you
yeah it's a it's a strange thing it's uh
because it's not just me it's my brother
and i both at the same time
we uh wonder about that yeah
we i would say that in our 20s
we were both kind of on different paths
and he was studying
uh math computer science and i was
studying art
we're close like a year and a half away
from each other so we're kind of we're
always we've already been very closely
younger
and uh sorry are you younger or older
i'm older yeah i'm i'm a year half older
than he is
and so we we started
i started reading post-modern
philosophies i was reading and i was
reading
i was reading uh you know just
the the whole crew um i was yeah
wrote a little book called mythologies
which really had a big
impact just really quick so what had you
actually read those
what was it part of art school or like
what had you it was an art school that
kind of
pushed me in that direction because the
the i took i took a few
philosophies of art classes and so they
were having us read these authors um
it's like what's dude so i'm i'm
familiar with art school
i moved to san francisco to go to art
school yeah
that's when i learned about heidegger
and i learned about jagdish
and then that took me on a like a road
of my own and that's when i
started reading um and uh
and i remember back had a little book
called mythologies
where he was trying to show the
mythological patterns in different
social uh
manifestations and he was doing it as a
way to mock them like
not as a way to mock them but as a way
to try to deconstruct them
but i remember leaving reading those
books and thinking this is awesome right
like it's all i like
i didn't see it as something like a
marxist desire to destroy these patterns
i thought this is awesome and and so
and i remember reading um a portrait of
an artist
and uh being really hit by joyce's use
of pattern and so i was like i was in
the modern
like in the modern world and um and so
then i became
interested in trying to create symbolic
languages and
when in art school i became pretty much
obsessed with
uh anselm kiefer who's a german artist
who
who does these kind of these he he
used his imagery and he creates kind of
symbolic references within his
he uses kind of this intertextual
language within his paintings and stuff
um referencing mythological characters
and and all of that and so
i was kind of trying to do it on my own
and and it just wasn't working out and
at the same time my brother was reading
uh discovering uh rabbinic
literature so he had when he was 16 he
decided to learn hebrew
on his own and then started reading uh
you know
rabbinic literature and mystical judaism
so we kind of had discussions and
discussions and discussions and
because you know we would just talk
every day for hours and hours and hours
and we kind of created
all even this like weird hermetic
language that if you would listen to a
conversation of ours you
you just wouldn't understand what we
were talking about
um and uh and then both of us he
discovered uh this author first
an author's name is renegade he's a
french traditionalist
and uh when he read uh geno he said my
brother said you have to read this like
this this is what we've been looking for
for years like we've been looking for
this forever and so when i read you know
it really
reshaped my thinking you know he he was
he there's a lot of problems with that
author like serious problems that's why
i don't quote
him uh too much because he has a lot a
lot of
remainder of occultism and his work and
there's a lot of
weird associations he's had but
nonetheless his
insight into symbolism was just beyond
anything i'd ever seen
so he wrote a book called uh called um
what is it that it's because i have it
in french uh the the symbols of sacred
science
he wrote a book called the great triad
he had several books where he
he worked out these these symbolic
patterns and um
and then so i kind of was trained that
way and then i
started to read the church fathers and
saw that no it's all there in
christianity it's all the air and the
father's insane gregor nissan
i found the fathers that really i felt
had
had that intuition and uh yeah and all
that led me to become orthodox
right it's gonna be maximus and father
of gregor of nisa
senator from the syrian all the neo yeah
those are really sonic
yeah yeah all the neopro
platonic i just started reading um um
saint maximus uh the cosmic um
was causing mystery yeah yeah just
started yeah it's a nice little
book because they they they've chosen
the text and so they
they kind of chose it to write they
really chose the right text some of
those
some of those are just just blow you
away some of these because they're so
short and he just kind of says things
and it just
yeah get to yeah he does something he
seems like saying maximus is
he's at least when i think
like when i at least the way it occurs
to me like when i look at just
all the stuff like st maximus like
stands out with something i don't know
exactly what it is
but there's something he gets or some or
way he says it or a place he's standing
that just seems to be
fundamental is that your experience with
him or what's oh yeah i think that
he offers up gold and uh and you have to
be careful because he does it in very
succinct way and so and so you have to
be careful because you can go
you can miss it and so you have to read
like his little text like his little
ambiguous or his little
you have to just kind of take your time
and then read every sentence from
of that of that text and just kind of
slow down because
he's kind of he's not he's not gonna
start blabbing he's really going to give
you to you in these
these very powerful um images and so
so he's definitely yeah he's i mean you
if you
once you've read saint maximus and
you've kind of understood what he talks
about then
then then a lot of and i think it's
easier to know that i
the things i'm talking about i'm not
taking it out of my own imagination you
know
it's like i will take say maximus and i
will
definitely apply some of the patterns
the things that he didn't apply like
i'll interpret things that he didn't
interpret but the main the main thrust
of his vision of this unit of
heaven and earth and you know all of
this
and then ephraim especially like the
mountain all of these things i take from
from these fathers so
interesting so you so you were so so
basically like you were in art school
right and then you started getting
assigned these books and you started
cracking them open and you're like this
is
this is you're reading their symbology
and their distinctions
right now before that was was your like
did you have much of an intellectual
life before that like what was your
relationship to all this stuff before
before well i mean my father my father
was a
very intelligent thoughtful person
and so in our house you know curiosity
and
discussion was encouraged and we we
definitely always saw both my brother
and i always saw my father as a very
intelligent and thoughtful person and i
i have several memories of my father
piercing through the appearances like
where he sees things happening and then
you know and then he says something to
us
and i can see that he kind of see
through the veils you know
um and so i think that he he they're
definitely a legacy coming from him in
terms of uh
in terms of a desire to kind of to go
further and to see through the
appearances you could say
um but it's definitely in university
like most people it's university that
that really kind of forces you to deal
with this stuff because they
kind of you know a it's a it's a really
high you know really
intense moment of thought and end of
discussion and of uh
you know exploration you have time to
read you have you don't have a lot of
words in life and so
it really is a good time for for that it
must have been just an amazing time
like with you it was existentially
difficult though
because it was uh because it it was this
crisis because i grew up in an
evangelical world
and so it was a crisis for me because i
couldn't reconcile
what i was discovering and the the
powerful
imagery and the powerful patterns i was
discovering i was struggling to
reconcile it with
my surrounding and so you mean at art
school
or i mean just through art school and
then later discovering
these symbolic thinkers even in art
school like i was while i was in art
school i was
i was writing and directing these plays
um in the kind of evangelical world and
so these huge
like massive productions with like 30
people and there was music and
and uh and so i was directing these
these play the last play i
wrote man it is like i don't think i
don't
i'm surprised even put it on because it
was it was it was really i was taking
all of this stuff that i was dealing
with uh it was about the bronze serpent
and the idea of like casting down idols
but building idols and
it was about an architect whose
buildings fall down and so you had this
massive sandbox on the stage and uh and
and then you would have this person
build up these things and they would
always fall
and so it was like this whole like
trying to deal with the problem of
post-modernism uh it's like i i can't
believe they even put it on but
nonetheless they did and so
you could feel like in that play that i
was struggling that i was like just
struggling to kind of
to fit it all together you know because
yeah i was being ripped apart in a way
and it's really the discovery of
orthodoxy
and just the traditional church fathers
which were finally a
a reconciliation for me because i think
that without that i probably at some
point
might have stopped being a christian
because you know it's like i was i
always loved christ
i knew that i belonged to christ but
then i looked around me
and i felt like what i was seeing was
extremely uh
superficial right and in
in what were the things that you were
kind of seeing was it was it like
the event like how is evangelistic
christianity different than
orthodox or or things or things that
involved it like
the older church fathers is that kind of
what
started to rip apart or part of what
yeah for sure because there's a
there's like a there's something
arbitrary about
the way that scripture is presented and
it has to do with
at least in the it's not all these
churches they're just the
where ones i grew up in and it didn't
help that
like i'll blame my father it didn't help
that my father was really smart and was
actually questioning and always
trying to pierce through and so at the
same time being in a situation where
people
would talk about the bible as if it's
it's like this and it's also because
they were so scientific and
materialistic materialist minded and so
and so then they would talk about
scripture as if it's like as if they're
describing a car
and and uh and it's like here are the
parts and this is how it works right
it's like okay so
adam and eve sinned in the garden they
did something bad and so in order to
solve that problem
then god you know sent jesus to die to
in their place
and it's like it's like it's it's like
it's like a two plus two equals four and
then
then because of that now if you believe
in that then you go to heaven
when you die and it's like that really
is not enough it's just not enough
it's just not i'm sorry it's just not
yeah
and so so when i started to see
like when i let's like when i started to
see that the pattern of
genesis is the same as the pattern of
moses
crossing the red sea and it's like
but then no one around me wanted to
acknowledge that because they felt like
if they acknowledged that
they were they were somehow damaging the
authenticity the material authenticity
of the story it's as if if i can show
that there's a pattern in the in the
story
then i am somehow saying that it's just
a story
right that it's not actually something
that happened because things that happen
in the world don't have patterns which
is
obviously not true um but it's weird
because i think that we're
if we're in a different space now even
then when i converted to orthodoxy
so for example like there's an amazing
uh group of guys called the bible
project and they're doing these videos
on
on on the bible and it's and it's like
if there's
full they all of a sudden they have
these perceptions of all these patterns
and this
this the way that the text is
constructed everything
and i'm thinking okay i think we might
be in a different space now than what i
was let's say 20 years ago when i
would have heard it right right i
appreciate i really appreciate what you
said about like it was
it was actually the pr like the post
monitors that really open all this
up right in a big way right and also i
also
i also appreciated what you said about
your dad i mean actually my dad's
kind of my dad has something in him
like that but like some of the best
moments with my dad are actually moments
where he
he said something that was just piercing
and revealing of something right like
those are
those are actually now you said i really
thought about it that
precisely before but now i think about
some of the best moments
my dad were always ones where he'd say
something that like
where he would reduce the entire
universe of my experience down to a like
a bumper sticker that kind of opened
it up again or something right like yeah
like an aphorism that would contain it
something like that yeah
i remember yeah and there's a certain
sense in which
yeah i think actually it's funny i never
really thought about with my dad
but like that's that there's something
about
those moments that
i think taught me to listen in some way
it like yeah
in some way i just i mean i can feel
that kind of in my body as i'm talking
about this kind of just open
like that you can do that with your you
can go from you can take your own
experience right
and like you can somehow see all of
reality in your
whole experience in a way that has you
relate differently to your experience
you can listen that way like i think my
dad had these yeah so i
i think i sympathetically appreciate
what you said about your dad
right i mean we were very fortunate i
think
you know yeah and like in my family
my family really fostered also just
the capacity to do the thing that you're
gonna do you know and that was something
that was really important in my family
so my
my youngest brother was actually a
professional skateboarder for several
years
there he was you know he lived in
california yeah he lived in he lived in
long beach
did that whole thing for for for several
years
and uh and then matsuya who is more kind
of a
mathematician type and developed his
symbolic thinking
you know almost like uh like a pure
science
and then i'm more the artist you know i
my
vision my approach is simply is more
lyrical and kind of messier
than my brother because matt syria is
like mature shoots like arrows you know
his
all his chapters are like three pages
and they're like sorry
he wrote he's the one that wrote the
book right about like he wrote
uh yes the language of creation yeah
that one is goes right to it
i could never write a book like that you
know because he just
shoots like i tell people go slow
because it's kind of like reading sam
access where
like he he there's no mincing of words
in there you know there's nothing extra
even the footnotes like i tell people
the best stuff's in the footnotes
they're there for a reason don't miss
them
[Laughter]
so when you were going through so there
was the part where it was incredible
when you're in college right well so
it's like the logos is opening up in
this completely different way
but then it was opening up to a degree
where you couldn't make sense
of like your current experience and your
past experience
without it feeling threatened right
in some way it was hard to it was hard
to join
all of it together and also also because
i was an artist and
and i was you know i grew up in a
baptist church which
although not openly hostile to visual
art it's at least
implicitly hostile to visual art and so
and so it just wasn't working it just
wasn't fitting together and so
and i feel like yeah i'm uh
i'm happy of of how things happened and
how things kind of
brought me to where to where i am
and then when and then the cri the
crisis part of it
like was that when you um
did it start to resolve when you found
it in the church fathers
as you were talking about yeah
definitely oh yeah
when i read you know like when i read
sandy irenaeus for example it's like san
diego's he's really
back there i mean he's one of their
early fathers and and he
has sandy ernest has a very powerful
symbolic understanding he
the thing is that it's not it's hard
because his writing
he just drops these things in his
writings
you can't it's not like when people ask
me like where in san diego i'm like i
don't remember because
it's it's not like he's written about it
it's just kind of all of a sudden you're
reading and versus heresies and then
like this thing drops like this this
massive knowledge drops
um and so like when i read early fathers
like san irenaeus
and uh you know even saint clement of
rome for example
i thought okay man there's something
missing this is there
you know this is it was all there and
then it kind of went away
and i got very very excited like i was
really excited
to read the church fathers i was
devouring
you know like saying when i read life of
moses i was just yeah
like where has this been all my life you
know this is so amazing
so i'm just saying i want to get i want
to just kind of get that because i think
i just
kind of got a little bit so it's like
there's the way where the patterns
actually had everything
like erupt it's like ecstatic on one
level but then kind of
also questions everything and then you
and it was it after art school that you
found yeah it was
after right yeah and the thing the thing
also the thing
the positive thing about growing up in a
protestant
church like a really positive thing is
that the fact that they really focus on
the bible
means that you know the stuff so it's
like i had
the stories the stories were stored in
my memory
like i knew the bible stories like i
knew the scripture
i knew what christ said i knew what
saint paul said and so but it was there
in almost like a latent form
and then all of a sudden when i started
to see
the the patterns then it was like
it's as if someone like someone opened
up the curtain
to my past experience and then just
connected it all together
right because it's as if it's it's
almost like you're watching a movie
you're watching a movie that has a that
has a surprise ending
you're watching the movie and you're
kind of like okay this is okay you know
i get it i get it i get it and then all
of a sudden
they show you something that reveals the
whole thing from the beginning
and so that was my experience it was
like because i had it all there it's not
like i was learning new things it was
just connecting things that i already
knew
and so to me that was probably the most
intense like let's say
the the most intense uh moments of
kind of ecstasy were these moments where
all of a sudden
something i've known since i was eight
years old all of a sudden
just kind of smashed together they're
like and then
it shines like it becomes bright you
know i don't know what else to say
yeah yeah i totally get it
[Laughter]
totally again it's funny like when you
said about the latent
right it's like back there they're
stories that like you know in the back
your hand
they're just part of the background and
then you're looking and everything's
like ripping apart and but it's luminous
but yet it's threatening and then
and then all of a sudden you look back
and then your own history it's god
that's so interesting like your own
floor reveals itself to you but it's
like
it's not new yeah yeah you're right new
information
amazing that's really amazing to
hear to imagine yeah it's funny
you gotta be like talking about my
myself so much i'm not used to doing
that like
it's like i feel like i'm giving my
testimony here oh it's becoming a little
embarrassing
yeah yeah this is where my curiosities
go because it
because i can always feel i can always
feel your videos it's like
like look like the only reason that
you're talking about all this stuff is
because you
are it's part of your experience right
like
and i just have always had these
questions about like in what way is a
part of your experience you've mentioned
a few of these things right so that's
just these things i've been curious
about right because i know that yeah
for me it's like these kinds of my life
is defined by
these my own version of these kinds of
things where it's like
right like moments where i'm in hell and
it all looks like it's gonna go over
and then something happens and then it
connects to everything else and then
like your whole history makes sense and
like it's
it's um through you know it's funny and
actually
it pop part of it for me and i've always
had a heart been not having i don't know
if i've been able to communicate this
i haven't been satisfied the way i've
been able to communicate this
how how when you read something right
when you read heidegger right right
so you read a text that's like
you sense that something's there you
sense it like but it's just beyond
what you know and then there's the act
of reading it
right which is and i think this has
something to do with my learning
disability and
dyslexic and stuff like that but
that there's a way of getting into this
information if you want to call it
information or knowledge
right and that if you practice reading
it
that you look up from the book and then
you start to see
it somehow like it's what i felt like
with heidegger without knowing it
heidegger was
teaching me how to see yeah that's what
it was especially heidegger like of all
people
it's as if you to understand heidegger
you have to
you have to enact it it's not just
it you can't just be like a mental
understanding right you know and i think
that also matsir's book
that's how he wanted to write it you
know so he wanted to write it in a way
that
this is going to make sense when you
apply it not when you're not just when
you're reading it it has to find body
um and i i agree i think that that's
that's that's that
especially someone like heidegger it's
like you really have to
you lift your eyes up and all of a
sudden it's changed you and you don't
totally understand
why you know or how yeah like yet for me
it was
i mean i really didn't have any idea
because we
what was happening is right at the time
that like circling started to happen
right um was the same time when i
started reading
a friend of mine had a book on heidegger
and started talking about being and i'm
like
and i just first it just glowed and so i
just followed it
and at the time we lived in san
francisco i lived in san francisco i was
right down
down the hill from the artistic tube
and um they had barnes and nobles across
the street
and i was a poor student so i'd go there
no one like you know bought the
heidegger books right so i'd go there
and i would just like have the whole
library to myself and i'd go in there
drink drink coffee and read being in
time i have no
idea what i just read i remember i think
i was reading being in time for
two months before i knew what da sein
actually meant
all right so but the uh
but i didn't really know what the
connection was between that
and circling until two two and a half
years later
right when because i read and then i go
circle on the beach and
in our courses and all these different
ways that we do that right and i go back
and forth back and forth and then
like some at some point i overheard
the the the style of the language that
came
out of all of that as it started to
become like a thing which i have mixed
feelings about its thingliness but like
um when he started talking about oh
getting your world
our world and background and foreground
and i started to notice that it started
to make its way in the
into the lingo of of
of the practice and then i heard it
other people talk about it and i was
like
oh wait a minute this is the same this
is heideggerian speak and i'm like oh
very funny
right this this kind of so there's
something about
a little bit of what you're talking
about that's familiar to me right
like it gets you at a it gets you at a
level that's
that you don't necessarily understand at
the time
that you're learning what you're
learning right until it becomes manifest
in your perception somehow
or in the way that your experience lays
itself out to you and shows itself to
you
um yeah yeah no that makes sounds like
it really happened in a big way
and that that was actually the way that
you
stepped into your the orthodox path
right
no definitely i think yeah i think it
happened a little bit
it happened a bit before that i even
found orthodoxy because at first
i was sad because i i was like
oh here it is and the father is here it
is but then it's gone like it's
it's nowhere the same with the art like
when i discovered medieval art
and the how patterned it was and just
how it was this amazing
intertextual you know algebra of of
language
and i thought wow this is amazing when
they're gone like it's it's all gone now
and that's and in reading uh
and discovering the orthodox church and
realizing that it was all still alive in
the orthodox church is
is one of the things that made me say
okay well this is it like
because i you know to be in i cannot to
kind of dive into the language of
iconography you could do it in an
archaeological way but then
that's not the point right right if
we're talking about these
ways of embodying and these ways of
existing in the world that if i'm going
to study
an ancient language like an archaeology
archaeologist and i'm alienating myself
constantly but
i wanted to be in the language and so i
had to kind of find a path where i could
do that and
yeah and and and that's what it is like
the icons i make are made for people
for churches they're not idiosyncratic
objects they're
objects that actually exist in people's
lives to to foster their spiritual
practice or to to celebrate something so
yeah that's great wow that must have
been something
to kind of realize and it was that
synonymous when
like when you were you already carving
um iconography when you joined when you
joined
into no this is actually no after you
went in it kind of yeah it kind of came
together
where i want i i wanted i started
attending an orthodox church when i
was looking to paint icons the carving
icons is almost
accidental because i i wanted to paint
icons because everybody who becomes
orthodox
wants to paint icons because that's
that's what is the main tradition
but i i couldn't find a teacher
and i was very eager like i was really
eager to do it and so
i ended up my parents cut down a tree in
their yard
and they had this wood there was like a
linden tree so they said oh this
this lindenwood we hear is good for
carving would you like some pieces to
kind of fiddle around with it and so
then i was like yeah
and i said i need i want to carve a
cross like i want to carve a
blessing cross so i kind of carved this
thing with like exacto knives i didn't
have any tools i
took forever to like and it's horrible i
still have it right
it was really bad uh but i really
enjoyed it and so it was almost like uh
it was almost it was obviously not
accidental but it was
it was not what i would have imagined
that i would carve icons it just kind of
presented itself to me and then i did it
and
and i continued and there you go and
here we are
whoa wow wow that's great
it's it's great to get to know you
thanks for thanks for coming on
i've been really appreciative it's my
pleasure i i feel like you got to know
me but i didn't get to know you very
much though yeah we could do no i mean
we could do another one
yeah that'd be nice i'd like to because
i i don't totally understand what the
circling thing is because
i hear circling but i don't know what it
is and i don't totally understand
yeah well i can just give you this that
this short version of it
is yeah go for it but what what i still
find i'm still finding out what it is
for me that's my experience of it right
um but it's
circling is is and i think it
i think it's helpful to understand that
i
feel i'm stuck in in and i didn't
understand this until
kind of probably about eight ten years
into it i started to get like oh
okay the the what's that what is this
responding to
i think it's directly in response
to that we've it's only been i think it
first started with the answering machine
but what really got big
you know with texting right and all
these different
all these different social media things
where
we were able to separate you became cons
like you were able to consistently
separate
like the basic exchange of interaction
they used to always have to do in person
or on the phone right yeah right and you
know those interactions are basically
how you learn
how that's how you become a self is
through those social interactions right
yeah it's only been i don't know 15
years or so
since you've introduced a division where
you don't have to do most of them
right and because they're filled with so
much ambiguity and so much
discomfort that just well
also the same thing i think the same
thing happened with our bodies right
with industrial revolution brought
machines brought everything
to a small circle in front of us so to
function move anymore and then we got
fat
right and then you had this whole
different transformation of what even a
body was and now you have
gyms and these ways of trying to
somewhat deal with that right which has
been transformative i think the same
thing's happening with a relationship
and i'm and i'm realizing like part of
part of
why circling has gotten so big is
because it just ha it happens to be
a it's basically a yoga that just
basically takes whatever it is whatever
it is
at the most basic level
if you're to take the the asanas
of all the all of the impactful personal
conversations that have been
like life-changing or deep or intimate
that have been nourishing
right if you're just to basically take
the elements of that
and make them kind of postures if you
will
um circling just basically
getting together in groups and taking
those postures of listening
of of speaking of communicating
that invite those moments and i
and it took me a while to realize that i
think
a lot of why it's gotten so big and
people have responded to it because
basically it's
it's very much like a gym
a gym with our bodies is a response
right to
that we don't move anymore so we have to
go into an environment in order to move
i think something similar is happening
with circling
um so it's basically it's a practice um
and of course the practice when people
start doing it they start having really
really really deep
spiritual kinds of experiences really
moments where they wake up and stuff
but it's essentially it's a yoga um
for relationship and intimacy i would
say okay
and then i'll have to definitely look
into it then yeah yeah yeah i don't
think i've heard it i've seen i've seen
you talk about it
and i've heard john viveki mention it
and stuff but i don't i haven't had the
time to kind of look into it yeah
and then john's frame with it is like
you know it's like it's essential
this he sees it as kind of an essential
in in his terminology the ecology of
practices that he talked about that he
talks
yeah yeah yeah i really i didn't realize
we talked for like an hour and a half i
never do that you got me really in a
weird in like
a good space i guess so i appreciate it
thanks a lot
yeah i really appreciate it too let's do
it again sometimes
yeah listen touch all right it's good to
talk to you bye-bye bye
as you've noticed in the past few weeks
i have been having
broader conversations trying to stretch
out
my thinking trying to see trying to test
it trying to see where it sticks where
i'm having trouble to communicate and so
if you
have some ideas of the type of people
you would like to watch me
talk to and you would be interested in
seeing the exchange please write them in
the comments section
i will be paying attention to that and
seeing how what interests people and
what kind of discussion we can have
if it's someone that i can access and
would be willing to come to talk to me
as you might have guessed we are not
necessarily on
in the good graces of the youtube
algorithm and so
please share these conversations that
you feel they are useful
i have a lot planned for 2021
which will probably be as crazy or
more so than 2020 and so hopefully
we'll be there to talk about it and to
try to make sense of what is going on
and so thanks for your attention
and i'll talk to everybody very soon